今天我們來聊一個很有趣的創新案例。想像一下，如果有人跟你說，你可以刺青，但完全不會痛，而且還能讓它消失，你會不會覺得這是在開玩笑？
當然會啊！我聽到這個就覺得出乎意料，刺青最讓人卻步的就是痛和永久性，如果這兩個點都能解決，那根本就不是刺青了。這到底是真的還是噱頭啊？
其實這不是噱頭，是真的。英國倫敦的生技新創CipherX就推出了全球首款「微點刺青」技術，他們用的方法跟我們傳統認知的刺青非常不一樣。
怎麼說呢？他們具體是怎麼做到的？總不可能變魔術吧？
他們不是用傳統的刺青機，而是採用生物醫學領域的「微針技術」。產品外觀更像是一塊貼片，上面有大量由色料跟生物相容性聚合物做成的微針。
等等，這裡我有疑問。微針？所以是把針貼在皮膚上？這聽起來還是會痛啊，而且貼片怎麼能變成圖案？
共同創辦人Ferdinand Kohle解釋說，這些微針的尺寸非常細小，比一般注射針或刺青針都細。當你把它貼附在皮膚上，透過專用塗抹器按壓，微針會進入表皮層然後逐漸溶解，把色料留在指定位置形成圖案。
所以痛感真的能避免？如果深入皮膚，怎麼可能不痛？
文章提到，微針並不會深入到真皮層，也就是我們痛覺神經比較密集的地方，所以多數人在施作時幾乎不會感受到明顯疼痛。整個貼附過程大約15分鐘就能完成，而且不像傳統刺青需要繁複的傷口照護。
嗯，聽起來有點道理。那這種「可消失」是怎麼回事？會不會過沒多久就模糊了？
原文沒有明確說明會維持多久才會消失，但它強調了「可消失的紋身體驗」，這點我覺得很重要。它不是永久的，所以才吸引到那些怕痛、怕後悔的人。
但這樣一來，他們是不是就跟傳統刺青師搶生意了？這種模式能夠撐得久嗎？那些追求藝術感的大型刺青需求，他們怎麼滿足？
其實CipherX並沒有把自己定位成傳統刺青的取代者，他們想開拓一個全新的市場。現階段微點刺青只提供幾款固定圖樣，尺寸大概在3到11毫米之間，比較像符號或極簡風格。
尺寸這麼小，那對於追求個人化、大圖案的客戶來說，可能就沒什麼吸引力了。這市場會不會太小眾？
他們未來計畫開放更多圖案選擇，也提供客製化服務。但重點是，他們瞄準的是那些「因害怕疼痛、擔心刺青過程而始終裹足不前」的人。這群人以前根本不是刺青市場的顧客。
這樣說來，CipherX是把一個原本不會考慮刺青的人，變成新的潛在客戶。這點倒是挺有意思的。
對，這就是我覺得這個案例最厲害的地方。它啟發我們，在經營任何產品或服務時，都可以思考「我們有沒有辦法改變這個行業的核心屬性，去解決一些深層的痛點？」
如果我是個小店老闆，這對我有什麼啟發？我總不能也去開發什麼生物科技產品吧？
其實不一定要是高科技。比如說，如果你開一家咖啡店，你可能會想，客人是不是因為趕時間而很少內用？你能不能推出一個「超快速取餐」服務，或是開發一款「不用洗杯子」的攜帶型咖啡包，去解決客人沒時間的痛點？
我懂了，就是重新定義產品的體驗，讓它更符合某些顧客的需求，即使跟主流有點不同。那一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶到工作裡嗎？
我覺得可以。比如你手上有一個專案，過去大家可能都覺得「這個案子很花時間/很複雜/很難溝通」。你就可以想想，有沒有辦法用「微點紋身機」的精神，去簡化流程，減少大家的痛苦？
讓它變得無痛、可修改、輕量化。就像一個複雜的報告，能不能先做一個「微報告」給主管看看方向，而不是一次生出一個大部頭，結果方向錯了又得重來？
沒錯，就像CipherX用微針取代傳統刺青針，你也可以思考，你的工作流程裡有沒有哪個「針」，是讓大家感到疼痛或麻煩的？有沒有可能用更輕巧、更彈性的方式去取代它？
這點其實不容易做到，因為常常大家習慣了舊做法，很難從根本上改變。但這個案例確實提供了一個不同的思考角度。
是啊。它好像也提醒了我們，有時候創新並不是要取代舊的，而是去創造一個全新的可能性，服務那些過去被忽略的需求。